le président américain a accueilli par
volodymir Zelenski et son épouse on
parle de liberté de la démocratie en
Europe on parle de l'histoire les
Américains pensent à tous les ukrainiens
et à tous les enfants Ukrainiens dans
leur prière un perturbable malgré les
sirènes Joe Biden marche tranquillement
aux côtés de volodi mirzelenski dans les
rues de Kiev nous avons annoncé de
nouvelles aides elles inclut des
munitions d'artillerie des lances
missiles des systèmes antiblindés et des
radars de surveillance aériennes pour
aider à protéger l'Ukraine contre les
bombardements aériens nous allons
utiliser c'est une nouveauté le
mécanisme de la facilité européenne de
paix pour permettre des achats directs
de munitions européennes par l'Ukraine
et puis nous allons aussi avancer sur le
contenu du dixième la question car c'est
déjà le dixième nous avons eu une large
discussion sur l'engagement de nos
équipes cette discussion nous rapproche
de la victoire et nous espérons que ces
années 2023 deviendra l'année de la
victoire les États-Unis ont fait part
d'une inquiétude que la Chine qui mène
déjà des entraînements militaires avec
la Russie livres à Moscou des armes pour
le conflit ukrainien
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
l’affirme publiquement
nous demandons instamment aux États-Unis
de réfléchir à leur propre action en
Ukraine devrait pour apaiser la
situation et d'arrêter de diffuser de
fausses informations ne jouons pas avec
les peurs des Français oui la situation
est difficile mais les résultats de
l'économie française sont solides le
chômage continue de baisser et je
maintiens que nous devrions sortir de
l'inflation vers la mi-2023 l'inquiétude
ce matin devant le magasin Galeries
Lafayette de Cannes depuis la demande de
mise sous sauvegarde de 26 boutiques de
l'enseigne les clients craignent de voir
leur magasin disparaître près de chez
eux enseigne de chaussures San Marina
placer en liquidation judiciaire aucune
offre de reprise n'a été retenue par la
justice plus de 600 salariés pertinent
si leur emploi la miss regarde
permettrait à ces magasins de poursuivre
leur activité le tribunal de commerce ne
s'est pas encore prononcé c'est
difficile aujourd'hui pour nos
compatriotes nous les protégeons mais je
ne veux pas que certains jouent avec les
peurs des Français en disant récession
chômage vague de faillite ça ne
correspond pas la réalité nous notre
responsabilité en tant que opposant à
cette réforme c'était de faire en sorte
qu'il ne puisse pas en 10 jours faire
voter le report de l'âge de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans c'est ce que nous
avons fait il faut qu'on se dise très
clairement les choses le 7 mars ce n'est
pas la prolongation du bordel qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale dans les
rues le 7 mars c'est la poursuite du
mouvement syndical orchestré dans une
première manifestation le 19 mars de 19
janvier qui s'est poursuivi depuis avec
différentes dates maîtriser par les
organisations syndicales il y a eu une
volonté de s'imposer voilà mais il va
falloir parce qu'il va falloir
retravailler je pense qu'il va que ça
signe un peu la fin d'un acte 1 de la
nuit Pesse qui a fonctionné jusqu'à
présent qui était issu de l'élection
présidentielle et que maintenant nous
passons nous devons passer à un acte 2
voici le lac de Montbel en Occitanie il
y a 2 ans aujourd'hui l'eau a presque
disparu dérive asséchées des pêcheurs
déboussolés les images satellites ont
capturé cette métamorphose entre les
mois de février 2022 et 2023
c'est pas une question d'hégémonie c'est
une question de vouloir
continuer sur la ligne de LFI elle est
finie enfin je pense qu'il y a une
différence entre elle et fille et la nu
oups partout en France des paysages
bouleversés comme ici à Béziers ou lorbe
est aux abonnés absents plus besoin de
pont le fleuve a disparu en plein mois
de février les prévisions ne se lancent
aussi loin mais ils affirment déjà que
d'ici l'été les nappes phréatiques ne
seront pas rechargées on va connaître
une nouvelle sécheresse en 2023